[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous nous allons
évoquer ici des sujets stratégiques et
sur ces dossiers sensibles je vais
partager avec vous mon interprétation le
droit international
interdit formellement le recours au
mercenariat dans tous les conflits mais
l'imprécision des textes permet aux
grandes puissances et à de nombreux
belligérants de le contourner
l'utilisation de ces sociétés militaires
privées
au delà du motif officiel de protection
des personnels et des entreprises permet
aussi de créer les conditions d'un
conflit renforcer ou instruire les armes
et assurer la sécurité dans les zones de
guerre et bien sûr intervenir contre ou
en appui de rebelles ou d'opposants il
est vrai comme l'a rappelé le général
castres aujourd'hui chez eux est celle
network que dans le far west des
relations internationales l'action
directe des états est souvent
disproportionnées et celle des services
de renseignement généralement très
insuffisante
au 20e siècle la
quasi-totalité des conflits africains
ont utilisé des mercenaires ou des
conseillers officiels ou pas d'ailleurs
comme par exemple les français au
katanga au biafra ou au congo les
cubains en angola où les américains en
ouganda rwanda puis au congo pour
installer le président kabila et
permettre aux rwandais par ailleurs de
récupérer le coltane de l'ituri depuis
l'américain m perry et dans l'ue c'est
qu'à kosovar a provoqué le conflit
contre le pouvoir central serbe ou
blackwater assurant la sécurité des
entreprises en irak et tout le monde se
souvient de ce qui s'est passé
tout le monde utilise ce type de
sociétés dont le personnel est constitué
de militaires très expérimenté pendant
la période de piraterie en océan indien
tandis que la france mobilisé ses
commandos marine les anglais les russes
les chinois ont utilisé des sociétés
militaires privées pour protéger leur
bateau ou pour ces derniers pour
sécuriser la route maritime de la soul
en libye on a vu la société russe vague
d'air renforcer le maréchal haftar qui
avait déjà le soutien très discret des
forces spéciales françaises tandis que
dans le même temps le président erdogan
envoyait pour aider le gouvernement de
tripoli des mercenaires issus des
groupes djihadistes réfugiés et glide en
syrie vous savez dans la zone turque au
nord et plus récemment on a vu le groupe
wagner s'implanter en centrafrique en
lieu et place de l'armée française puis
intervenir cette année pour tenter
d'arrêter une rébellion au mozambique
dans tous les cas ce genre d'action
n'est pas gratuite car ces groupes se
font rémunérer sous différentes formes
allant du paiement en espèces
à des concessions minières ou dut
licence d'exploitation récemment le
gouvernement français a violemment réagi
à l'annoncé d'un mémorandum d'intention
passé entre wagner et le gouvernement
malien en réalité le problème du mali
est plus complexe qu'il n'y paraît le
président malien a fait jouer en janvier
2013 la clause d'assistance militaire
avec la france devant le risque d'être
renversé par des rebelles principalement
j à dist venant du nord il comptait sur
notre armée pour écraser la rébellion
car son armée en était pas capable pour
la france était un moyen pratique de
réaffirmer sa puissance et son influence
dans la région du sahel et de l'afrique
francophone souvenez-vous en un an et
demi l'opération serval a magnifiquement
régler le problème en arrêtant la
colonne puis en pourchassant les groupes
jihadistes et en les éliminant mais il
est vite apparu évident aux experts et
aux militaires que la guerre allait
continuer car les jihadistes allait
continuer à recruter dans la zone
sahélienne comme le rappelle
régulièrement bernard lugan cela tenait
essentiellement à l'opposition entre le
sud qui gouvernait et le nord qui ne
bénéficiait d'aucun appui gouvernemental
car sa population était détesté par
celle du sud depuis au moins un
millénaire il fallait donc trouver une
solution consensuelle comme cela avait
été fait au niger il ya vingt-cinq ans
après la rébellion touareg menée par
mano dayak est contrôlé par les services
français
l'algérie a toujours considéré le mali
comme faisant partie de sa zone
d'influencé sans pour autant et envoyer
de troupes ayant 1300 km de frontière
commune elle ne veut pas voir se
reformer un noyau islamistes trop de
puissants au sud à partir des éléments
algérien kelly a repoussé oncle armée
française bief royet contre les
djihadistes elle avait donc réuni toutes
les parties en dehors des français pour
régler le problème politique et
territorial et cela s'était concrétisée
par les accords d'alger du 19 février
2015 qui n'ont jamais été appliquées par
le gouvernement de bamako à la fureur
des gens du nord bien sûr mais également
de ceux d'alger et c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que six mois plus tard avec
la réussite de cerval tous les éléments
étaient réunis pour réussir la mise en
place de l'accord et apporter la paix
c'est le moment où la france a lancé
l'opération barkan pour contrôler la
situation dans les pays du g5 sahel
qu'on l'appelle aujourd'hui avec l'aide
des armées locales
malheureusement elle a été
progressivement perçue est considérée
comme une armée d'occupation qui
protégeait les régimes en place au mali
mais aussi au tchad et c'était d'autant
plus mal vécue
quel empêché un grand nombre de trafics
traditionnelle dans cette région très
pauvre lors il est vrai que bamako
gangréné par la corruption à tous les
niveaux de l'état a laissé son pays se
faire infiltrer par le trafic de drogue
et était devenu la plaque tournante du
grand banditisme dans l'afrique
francophone il ne faut donc pas
s'étonner que les militaires maliens
excédé par la corruption et l'absence de
réaction de la france ait pris le
pouvoir en août 2020 avec l'approbation
des algériens et des russes avec ils
sont liés par un accord ou somaliens
signé en juin 2019 tout de suite les
nouveaux chefs du mali ont entamé
directement des négociations avec les
deux chefs djihadistes
amadou pouffa pour les peuls et iyad el
ghali pour les touareg
ils ont libéré une centaine de
prisonniers
au grand déplaisir des français
j'ajouterai que ils ont libéré en plus
on notre compte la fameuse sophie
pétrole 1 on est donc face à deux
stratégies pour obtenir la paix la
victoire militaire technique et
sécuritaire pour les français et la
négociation politique pour les locaux
appuyés par les algériens une des clés
de cette guerre et le chef touareg iyad
al ghali dont la famille vit à kidal qui
est qui a été depuis
1990 donc tous les mouvements de
libération ou d'autonomie de ce qu'on
appelle l'azawad ce territoire qui
correspond au nord-mali il a servi chez
kadhafi dans la garde de kadhafi il
s'est battu au tchad au liban puis il
est parti comme diplomate en arabie
saoudite et durant son séjour à jeddah
il est devenu islamiste depuis la
création du groupe djihadiste ançar dine
il est poursuivi par les forces
spéciales françaises mais il est de
notoriété publique
depuis 2014 pratiquement depuis le début
des opérations qu'il est protégé par les
autorités algériennes et bénéficier
d'une base arrière en algérie qu'il va
permet chaque fois qu'on allait le
prendre d'échappée et ceci d'ailleurs
aurait fait l'objet d' échanges verbaux
et téléphonique entre les présidents
bouteflika et mâcon mais
les algériens le protège car ils sont
convaincus que dans la mise en oeuvre
des accords d'alger
c'est lui qui pourra tenir le nord du
pays
selon olivier guitta dans sa lettre
global strates du 18 octobre le tout
puissant chef d'état-major l'armée
nationale populaire algérienne le
général saïd sean greer est à
l'offensive contre les français et
l'influencé française en afrique faut
ajouter qu'il est aussi un opposant
irréductible du maroc qui l'avait fait
prisonnier à l'époque de la guerre au
sahara espagnol vas-y considère le maroc
comme proche des américains depuis les
accords d'abraham et d'autre part le
maroc développe de très fortes relations
commerciales et financières avec tous
les pays d'afrique francophone alger des
sources concomitante des affaires
étrangères et de la défense
laisse entendre que l'algérie pourrait
même financer 70 % du coût des
mercenaires il vrai que l'arrivée de
wagner lui permettrait d'éloigner les
français est d'avoir une position
prédominante
auprès du gouvernement malien c'est dans
ce cadre qu'il a interdit brutalement le
survol de l'algérie par les avions
militaires français et veut couper le
ravitaillement en gaz et en pétrole dont
barkan bénéficie depuis huit ans alors
tout ceci explique la réaction
extrêmement violente du président macron
en dépit de ses bonnes relations avec le
président tom boon et de ses axes
successives de repentance on nous avons
l'occasion de parler pour améliorer la
situation entre les deux pays ar il est
vrai
emmanuel macron est le premier président
français il n'a pas connu la guerre est
parfait de service militaire
n'est allé à l'ère de la mondialisation
de l'économie ils maîtrisent mal les
rapports de force et l'organisation de
l'action leed il a donc dénoncé
fortement le complexe militaro politique
algérien ce qui a provoqué le rappel de
l'ambassadeur d'algérie
parallèlement au plan intérieur français
il a sanctionné le quai d'orsay en
limogeant le chef de la section
moyen-orient et afrique du nord il
n'avait rien vu venir mais
cela ne règle rien et tient plus de la
gesticulation
comme le déclare nicolas normand
l'ancien ambassadeur de france au mali
en 2006 dans une interview du 21 octobre
des déclarations du président macron le
25 septembre sur la réorganisation de
barkan ont été mal comprises elles ont
permis au premier ministre choquel maïga
d'accuser à l'onu la france
d'abandon en plein vol avec le retrait
de barkan et l'abandon des bases se
tisse à l'it kidal et tombouctou sans
consultation préalable et en violation
de l'esprit de coopération
bien sûr ils ignorent volontairement il
va rester 3000 soldats français dans le
dispositif
on appelle maintenant à kouba mais cela
lui permet de chercher un appui du côté
de la russie pour se retrouver moins
dépendant de la france
aujourd'hui j'ai le plaisir de recevoir
le général françois chauve en scic est
un expert et auteur on analyse
géopolitique qui pilote un blog qui
s'assure le site theatrum belli chargé
du domaine de la sécurité de la défense
il assume également des cours dans les
mêmes domaines dans plusieurs
universités compte tenu sa grande
expérience
je lui ai demandé de bien vouloir réagir
et compléter mon interprétation françois
bonjour d'abord alors revenons sur
revenant sur l'armée française sur
barques année la réorganisation qui
s'annonce qui est inquiète annoncé qui
va se faire qu'est ce qu'il faut en
penser ou comment tu la vois comment ça
se passe
déjà il faut bien dire que la france ne
se retire pas ni du mali du sahel nous
avons des engagements est temps qu'on
peut répondre à la demande des états de
crs de cette région nous serons là donc
il s'agit bien d'une transformation
d'une réorganisation dans laquelle nous
respectons la souveraineté des états et
nous continuerons d'appuyer leur action
contre le terrorisme
maintenant nous allons peut-être le
faire de manière différente une manière
différente en les soutenant mieux
peut-être et en participant - au combat
sauf en cas de besoin il ya des forces
nécessaires et suffisantes pour appuyer
l'armée malienne par exemple dans son
combat l'aforst à kouba qui est une
force spéciale
d'ailleurs spécifiant bien européenne
donc il n'ya pas que les français nous
sommes ici dans une logique
d'internalisation de ce conflit nous
sommes tous concernés par la lutte au
terrorisme et dès lors que c'est l'union
européenne ou des états européens qui
participent ça montre bien que nous
n'avons pas une volonté néocolonialistes
que certains opposants pourraient nous
opposer justement voilà d'autres on est
dans la transformation l'interphone
internationalisation du conflit le
soutien à l'armée locale à la formation
et bien sûr en respectant la
souveraineté des états alors on a
beaucoup parlé justement des guides la
qualité respective des différentes
armées locales un certains n'hésitent
pas à dire que pendant les tchadiens
sont d'excellents soldats d'autres le
sont moins ou sont moins entraînés ou au
moins d'équipements qu'est-ce qu'ils
font penser aujourd'hui l'expérience
déjà acquise fait que les armées locales
tu parlais de l'armée malienne par
exemple sont réellement meilleure
qu'elle n'était il ya sept huit ans
quand à l'époque où ça a commencé ou pas
à ton avis globalement bien sûr sans
aucun doute or c'est vrai tu viens de
citer les tchadiens ils ont une
réputation de guerrier qui n'est plus à
faire maintenant parlons surtout du ma
vie qui est notre problème d'aujourd'hui
ce problème du mali effectivement les
soldats maliens n'était pas à la hauteur
comme d'ailleurs dans beaucoup d'armées
en général africaine où ce n'est pas une
priorité on veut éviter une arme est
trop forte qui pourrait prendre le
pouvoir bon maintenant il semblerait
bien que sur le terrain notamment les
forces maliennes encadrés par les forces
spéciales de takouba commence à avoir de
résultats donc je crois que c'est une
dans la durée qu'on obtiendra des
résultats contre le terrorisme par les
armées locales car cette armée malienne
notamment aujourd'hui résiste mieux dans
ses bases elle est capable de prendre
quelques missions à son compte ce ne
sont plus les militaires français
forcément qu'ils sont aux premières
lignes ce sont les militaires maliens
donc je pense qu'on peut espérer un
succès de cette appropriation de ce thé
guerre est une guerre qui concerne les
maliens et pas uniquement la france
alors justement on à la guerre à
démarrer en 2013 un jam a quand même
maintenant un bon nombre d'années
pour les français ce que tu pense aussi
que pour l'armée française c'est une
guerre qui a été qui a permis de faire
évoluer la de la faire évoluer parce que
on avait connu la côte d'ivoire on avait
connu un certain nombre de comblain
centrafrique huit chantiers tout à
l'heure là c'est la plus longue de
toutes c'est la plus longue guerre qu'on
ait fait qu'est-ce que je crois oui tout
à fait mais je pense que et on revient
aux j'irai au discours de chef d'état
major français qui rappelle qu on doit
se préparer à la guerre de haute
intensité cette guerre de haute
intensité sait pas c'est que nous
faisons en afrique en afrique moi
j'appelle ça de la guerre
contre-insurrectionnelle contre une
guérilla ce n'est pas le même genre de
guerre donc nous avons beaucoup appris
nous avons maintenant une armée aguerrie
une armée de soldats est pas une et
seulement une armée de militaire il ya
une différence entre les deux nous avons
une belle armée française maintenant on
ne peut pas se contenter de faire de la
guerre contre-insurrectionnelle il ya
des conflits plus classique qui pourrait
s'annoncer dans l'avenir d'affaires axé
la culture vient là sur ce que vient de
dire effectivement le chef d'état major
des armées françaises qui a bien
expliqué ça récemment lisant qu'il
fallait en tenir non seulement pour les
hommes et pour les matériels à tout à
fait d'abord les matériels ne sont pas
les mêmes et puis relativisons quand
même le confident le cese si je peux me
permettre combien de combattants ennemis
face à nous quelques milliers sur dix
fois la superficie de la france est ce
que c'est une menace réelle pour la
france c'est sans doute une menace pour
le gouvernement local malien ou d'autres
de la région mais ce sont des menaces
limité ce n'est pas l'objectif premier
de la france de combattre cet ennemi là
l'objectif premier d'une armée française
en particulier c'est de défendre ses
frontières son territoire dans le cadre
d'autres alliances donc je crois que
nous serons des conflits que je
qualifierais mois de périphériques qui
font beaucoup de bien l'armée française
puisqu'elle s'aguerrit en permanence
mais ce n'est pas le conflit principal
auquel nous devons nous préparer merci
françois pour seule explication bc
complément d'explications très
intéressant qui choquera permettent bien
d'éclairer le débat au niveau de nos
auditeurs et puis on aura sa demande aux
occasions de parler d'autres problèmes
concernant toute la partie géopolitique
militaires et de défense et de sécurité
ils sont et spécialités merci et puis à
très bientôt valeur
au regard de la situation actuelle il
est clair que nous avons fait des
erreurs à l'humiliation initiale les
voir dû faire appel à l'armée française
s'est ajoutée dans le temps pour les
maliens une communication mal adapté
elle ne parle que des succès français
sans associer nos partenaires et à
l'évidence manque de compréhension du
contexte local politique et sociologie
et il va falloir en tirer les leçons et
cesser de mettre sur le compte de fée
news août campagne d' influence venus
d'ailleurs le ressenti l'état d'esprit
des populations
si on ne veut pas se retrouver comme les
américains en afghanistan il faut être
aussi réaliste l'application de l'accord
d'alger dont nous avons parlé même est
large et ne résoudra pas tout car parmi
les djihadistes certains groupes
poursuivent des buts différents les
autres de plus le mali ne peut le mettre
en oeuvre sans l'appui des grandes
puissances et de ses voisins alors il
est certain que l'arrivée de wagner ne
peut remplacer et français qui pourront
difficilement partir quoi qu'il en dise
ou quoi que son ministre en dise
puisqu'ils font partie de l'ensemble
solidaire des pays du g5 sahel et nous
l'avons évoqué tout à l'heure du groupe
européen takouba certes comme le
souhaitent les algériens cela
diminuerait l' influence française et
permettrait de construire à un axe très
fort alger bamako moscou mais cela ne
réglera pas le problème de fond de son
côté l'armée française a montré malgré
son efficacité qu'elle ne pouvait pas
gagner la paix et le quai d'orsay
la capacité à trouver une vraie solution
politique en définitive après neuf ans
de guerre tout reste à faire
à bientôt
[Musique]